in a matter of days several new laws
will go into effect in Nevada including
one that will limit the number of
classic license plates the state issues
you've seen them around town and in some
cases thought that doesn't quite look
like a classic vehicle right so the
state says some drivers are just using
these type of license plates to avoid
getting a smog check Joshua peguero digs
deeper into the law and its impact
for True classic car enthusiasts a car
like this they'll maybe drive 300 miles
a year and it'll be the third or fourth
car in the rotation but the state is
looking to clamped out on those
individuals who have a certain type of
classic car license plate but use the
vehicle full time Kevin Malone with the
DMV says the number of classic car
license plates increase three folds
since 2011. the primary reason that
those numbers went up was people trying
to claim the smog check exemption on
older cars that can't pass the smog
check or or people who just don't want
the hassle of doing the smog check
classic car owners will have to present
classic car insurance before registering
or renewing next year insurance for
these type of vehicles are usually
cheaper because a vehicle isn't driven
often Michael Cimino owns a vintage car
shop in Boulder City it's not
necessarily the car you could take the
kids to school in or or uh or go to the
grocery store in classic plates cost 36
dollars initially in ten dollars to
renew Cimino says that this law won't
impact true classic car owners now for
cars that are 25 years old and are
deemed classic cars that aren't really
collectible cars that's going to impose
you know some more hardship the DMV says
it started running ad campaigns
notifying classic car owners of the
change to the new law has taken effect
in January reporting in Boulder City
Joshua progero eight news now
classic car owners will also now have to
submit an odometer certification at the
time of registration or renewal